also leichter kommen zu dem Geld auf das
man ohnehin Anspruch hat denn bislang
nimmt nur eine Minderheit der
Berechtigten den Kinderzuschlag in
Anspruch dieser Paus von den Grünen ist
die zuständige Familienministerin und
jetzt bei uns voraus guten Abend guten
Abend wann ist denn dieser einfach zu
bedienende
kindergrundsicherungscheck dann am Netz
wenn wir das Gesetz verabschieden zum
1.1.2025 das ist das klare Ziel und
darauf haben wir uns als Bundesregierung
gestern verständigt dass der
Gesetzentwurf ist heute in Resort
Abstimmung gegangen und klappt das auch
Programmierung ist ja bei solchen Sachen
häufiger mal ein Problem um es
vorsichtig zu sagen wir arbeiten ja seit
gut einem Jahr an diesem Gesetzentwurf
und genau weil so etwas öfter passiert
dass man ersten Gesetz macht und sich
hinterher erst überlegt wie man kann man
es auch umsetzen haben wir diesmal von
Anfang an anders gemacht es wird die
Familienkasse der Bundesarbeitsagentur
sein die die zukünftige
kindergrundsicherungstelle ist und mit
der sind wir eben auch seit praktisch
einem Jahr ein sehr intensiven
Gesprächen und auch die warten dringend
auf den Gesetzentwurf damit sie anfangen
können mit der Programmierung jetzt hat
die Kollege und Kontrahent Christian
Lindner heute fast schon Schaden vor
darauf hingewiesen dass jetzt auch mal
die Grünen erleben würden wie lange und
kompliziert sowas in Deutschland ist er
selbst erlebt ist ja mit der Klima Geld
Auszahlung auf die wir ja immer noch
warten
also dieser Prozess ist wirklich anders
wir haben von Anfang an eben mit der
Bundesarbeitsagentur bereits geschaut
wir haben im Gesetz entsprechend
verankert worauf müssen wir achten damit
diese Digitalisierung auch wirklich
funktionieren kann und was wir
tatsächlich wollen ist dass wir
hinkommen von der hohlschuld der Bürger
hinzubringen Schuld des Staates damit
eben Familien sich konzentrieren können
auf das worum es geht eben gutes
Miteinander zu schaffen und sich nicht
zu existenzielle Sorgen machen müssen
mit der neuen
kindergrundsicherungsstelle werden wir
die eine Stelle haben für alle Familien
also nicht mehr stigmatisieren gehe ich
zum sozialamtlich zum Jobcenter oder wo
muss ich hin sondern die Familien wissen
das ist unsere eine Stelle und das ist
der zentrale Systemwechsel mit der
Kindergrundsicherung dass wir nicht mehr
unterscheiden zwischen den Familien
zwischen den verschiedenen Familien
sondern alle Familien wissen die Kinder
grundsicherungstelle die ist unsere
Ansprechpartnerin und die unterstützt
uns wenn wir einkommensschwierigkeiten
haben okay es ist also vor allem eine
Verwaltung und eine
digitalisierungreform wirklich etwas tun
gegen Kinderarmut in diesem reichen Land
Deutschland das kostet 12 Milliarden
Euro hatten sie mal gesagt jetzt sind
wir bei 2,4 Milliarden und eine halbe
Milliarde davon geht in die Verwaltung
mehr Geld für jede einzelne arme Familie
haben Sie also nicht bekommen
naja also die Bundesregierung hat ja
bereits einiges an Grundlagen gemacht
ich selber habe mich dafür eingesetzt
dass das Kindergeld auf 250 Euro erhöht
worden ist wir haben bereits 7
Milliarden Euro als Bundesregierung
zusätzlich für die Familien investiert
und wenn der kindergrundsicherungscheck
funktioniert und wenn die
Digitalisierung funktioniert dann werden
wir zum Beispiel hoffentlich zu einer 80
prozentigen Anspruchnahme kommen dann
werden das 6 Milliarden Euro sein also
der Erfolgsfaktor ist der ganz
entscheidend irgendwie locker oder geht
sie davon aus dass das dann die Folge
Regierung leisten muss am Ende
wir schaffen jetzt erstmal die
gesetzlichen Grundlagen und sorgen dafür
dass es tatsächlich funktioniert das all
die Familien die Anspruch auf eine
Leistung haben auch tatsächlich die
Leistung bekommen das ist einfach eine
Sache des Respekt ist dass wir dafür
sorgen dass die Gesetze die in
Deutschland gelten auch tatsächlich bei
allen Familien ankommen aber was sagen
sie denn zu denen die sagen eine
Familienministerin die ursprünglich mal
12 Milliarden für angemessen hielt jetzt
bei 2,4 Milliarden gelandet ist und
dabei einfach nicht fassen können wieso
es so ausgehen konnte
wir werden mit der Kindergrundsicherung
auch Leistungsverbesserungen machen wir
werden das nur zur kulturelle
Existenzminimum neu berechnen weil die
Kinder Regelsätze einfach nichts mehr
mit der aktuellen Realität zu tun haben
es ist einfach so Kinder egal welchen
alter es brauchen Platz zu Hause zum
Spielen oder auch zum Lernen das haben
wir bei Corona erlebt es ist einfach so
dass eine Waschmaschine in einer Familie
mit mehreren Kindern deutlich öfter in
Betrieb ist als in anderen
Konstellationen und es ist auch so dass
bei Kindern auch öfter mal was kaputt
geht so dass man eben auch zusätzliches
Geld braucht für Sanierungen wenn Dinge
kaputt gehen und deswegen machen wir
eine neue Berechnung so zu kulturellen
Existenzminimums also auch materiell
kommt mehr bei den Familien an 28 €
maximal im Monat sagen Rechnungen sagen
die Berechnungen und der Finanzminister
hat heute gesagt das wird keine
generellen Leistungserhöhungen geben
wir mit den Leuten aus der Praxis das
ist keine Kindergrundsicherung sagt der
Kinderschutzbund heute es ist nicht der
große Wurf sagt das Kinderhilfswerk er
verpasst sie haben dafür einen Eklat im
Bundeskabinett direkt nach der
Sommerpause verursacht fast die
Koalition gesprengt wenn Sie heute mal
so vielleicht ein bisschen sich
zurücklehnen und zurückblicken hat sich
das gelohnt
das hat sich auf jeden Fall gelohnt weil
wir brauchen die Kinder Grundsicherung
es lohnt sich für jedes Kind das von
dieser Kunde Grundsicherung profitiert
zu kämpfen und deswegen habe ich das
gemacht als Familienministerin das ist
mein Job mich für die Familien in diesem
Land einzusetzen und in der Sache ist
kein Schaden entstanden sondern heute
stehen wir da und haben das
wachstumsschancegesetz noch etwas
verbessert was wir in Meseberg
beschließen werden und wir haben uns
verständigt auf die Kinder
Grundsicherung beides zusammen ist das
was Deutschland braucht wir brauchen
klare Unterstützung des
Wirtschaftsstandortes aber wir brauchen
auch ein klares Signal für den
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt in
Deutschland für alle Familien und das
schafft die Kinder Grundsicherung aber
in dieser Höhe hätten sie es doch auch
bekommen können ohne den kleinen
Kabinett und ohne den Eindruck dass die
Koalition auch nach der Sommerpause
einfach immer weiter streitet
also ich kann ihn versichern dass wir
bei der Kindergrundsicherung sehr sehr
grundsätzliche Gespräche miteinander
hatten sehr sehr grundsätzliche
Verhandlungen es stimmt wir sind in
einem schwierigen wirtschaftlichen
Umfeld aber gerade diese Situation
brauchen wir eben auch Unterstützung für
den sozialen Zusammenhalt und da sind
die Familien gerade ganz entscheidend
sagt die Bundesfamilienministerin dieser
Pause vielen Dank für das Gespräch